bajo su reinado el mundo ha asistido al
nacimiento de la televisión en directo
de internet y de los celulares con
cámaras inventos con los que personajes
públicos empezaron a sufrir un creciente
escrutinio público en 1992 en lo que
ella describió como su annus horribilis
un enorme incendio arrasó el castillo de
windsor alimentando un escándalo sobre
quien pagaría la factura de la
reparación en
1992 no es un año que recordaré con un
placer total
al año siguiente la reina se convirtió
en la primera monarca de la historia en
pagar el impuesto sobre la renta y abrió
el palacio de buckingham al público con
la esperanza de utilizar el dinero
recaudado con las entradas para
restaurar el castillo de windsor ese
mismo año los tres matrimonios de sus
hijos se rompieron poniendo a prueba su
imagen pública el matrimonio de la
princesa diana- con el heredero al trono
el príncipe carlos se desmoronó en medio
de rumores de aventuras recibió una
publicidad sin precedentes ya que los
paparazzis seguían todos sus movimientos
desde el palacio de buckingham se
anuncia que con gran pesar el príncipe y
la princesa de gales han decidido
separarse
pero la simpatía del público estaba del
lado de diana un punto de inflexión se
produjo en 1997 cuando la reina
permaneció totalmente callada durante
una semana tras la trágica muerte de
diana alimentando las críticas por su
insensibilidad la reacción del público
obligó al palacio a revisar su imagen
las bodas se convirtieron en una
oportunidad para que la familia real se
reinventará bajo la mirada de la nación
en 2011 el nieto de la reina el príncipe
william se casó con kate middleton una
mujer sin antecedentes aristocráticos
se reforzaron las diferencias con la
generación anterior con los miembros de
la realeza libre de elegir parejas
ajenas a la nobleza y de seguir el amor
de una forma en la que la gente
corriente pueda identificarse fue
hermoso ella estaba absolutamente
impresionante y todo el mundo lo estaba
toda la familia real su familia fue
genial
siete años después en otro cuento de
hadas moderno el príncipe harry se casó
con la actriz estadounidense megan marco
una divorciada con una herencia étnica
mixta en una boda que combinó los
orígenes de ambos en la ceremonia de
apertura de los juegos olímpicos de
londres-2012
la reina mostró al mundo su sentido del
humor participó en una representación
con daniel craig en el papel de james
bond asombrando a los espectadores
cuando ella y el agente 007 aparecieron
saltando desde un helicóptero en el
stadio olimpico antes de ocupar su
asiento en el palco real
tecnológicamente la familia real también
ha avanzado con los tiempos creando sus
propias cuentas en las redes sociales lo
que llevó la pompa y ceremonia de la
monarquía a toda una generación de
jóvenes además de dar un vistazo a sus
proyectos y a su vida cotidiana